vísperas de su cumpleaños 77 es un
regalo del que Donald Trump hubiera
prescindido Este martes un maratón
judicial comienza para el expresidente
estadounidense en la corte Federal de
Miami Trump tendrá que comparecer ante
los jueces y la sesión comenzará con la
lectura de los 37 cargos que se le
imputan
se le acusa entre otras cosas de
mantener en secreto documentos de
defensa en su residencia personal de
obstrucción a la justicia y de
Conspiración según sus abogados se prevé
que el precandidato a las próximas
elecciones presidenciales se declare
inocente y se prevé también que se ha
puesto bajo arresto pero se evitarían
las formalidades habituales como las
esposas y la foto que acompañan al
arresto en las afueras del tribunal
donde se ha reforzado la seguridad por
temor a desórdenes algunos
incondicionales ya están allí para
prestarle su apoyo voy a estar allí me
voy desde el amanecer y otras personas
más que pudieron venir hoy vamos a
apoyar todo esto es una parodia ni
siquiera tiene sentido el sistema
judicial aquí es muy corrupto
a cargo de este explosivo caso para
Donald Trump está la jueza eiling Canon
aquí en el mismo nombre para el cargo en
2020 durante la fase de investigación la
jueza restringió el acceso de los
fiscales a los documentos clasificados y
nombró a un experto independiente para
examinarlos estas decisiones están
siendo impugnadas y es probable que sean
recorridas tras la primera audiencia del
multimillonario republicano después de
su comparecencia Trump viajará a su club
de golf en Nueva Jersey donde tiene
previsto dirigirse a sus partidarios